even before the general milli
revelations my next guest pledged to
stop all pentagon and state department
nominations
until secretaries austin ann blanken and
national security adviser sullivan
resign
and today in his senate testimony
lincoln still refused to take any
responsibility for afghanistan when
president biden took office in january
he inherited an agreement that his
predecessor had reached with the taliban
had he not followed through on his
predecessor's commitment attacks on our
forces and those of our allies would
have resumed
and the taliban's nationwide assault on
afghanistan's major cities
would have commenced
joining me now missouri senator josh
hawley senator
uh the lies the stonewalling the
misrepresentation of trump sheer
incompetence
and now the leaked millie
um chats is
is there anyone
trustworthy among biden's military or
diplomatic leadership his cabinet at
this point
you know it really makes you wonder if
anybody in this administration laura is
willing or able to tell the truth and
that's a dangerous spot to be in and as
the united states of america is the
people of this country i mean listen
what blinken was saying today just isn't
true he knows that that's not true this
administration materially altered the
conditions of withdrawal and they they
are the ones who are responsible joe
biden is responsible for the withdrawal
that resulted in 13 service members dead
that resulted in hundreds of american
civilians left behind and until there is
some accountability here i'm not going
to rubber stamp these nominees i'm not
going to let them just sail through the
senate there needs to be accountability
for the humiliation that this country
has suffered at the hands of joe biden
and can i just say this to laura for joe
biden to call this humiliation an
extraordinary success as he did to say
that the death of these these marines
and service members that these civilians
left behind the enemy that's a success
that's not a success it's a disgrace
well it's more than blanken refusing to
take responsibility here it's
putting america's national security
in jeopardy
for everything this says to the rest of
the world most notably what it says to
our chinese uh
adversaries and to that point senator
the washington post's uh josh rogan
got some additional context about
millie's actions from a senior trump
national security official
and that official said that millie
was making these phone calls with china
at a time when the u.s government was in
the middle of very complicated
discussions with and actions against the
prc for him to take this sort of action
without any interagency coordination is
astonishing official goes on to say the
risk is that milly could have caused the
chinese to miscalculate and take some
sort of diplomatic economic or military
action with far-ranging consequences
because he was giving the wrong signal
having no understanding of the context
in which he was making the call
general
that does open eyes
does it not no that does
i mean
how does millie not
at this point
be forced to resign and then be brought
up on charges
but before a military tribunal at the
very least
well i i was just going to say i mean
what he is doing here if this were if
these reports are accurate laura what he
has done general milley is go outside
the chain of command he's broken the
chain of command he has threatened
the constitutional principle of civilian
control of the military he doesn't have
the right he doesn't have the authority
to contact
our opponents in beijing and tell them
that he will inform them about any
action we might take before we take it i
mean i can't believe i'm reading this i
hope these reports are inaccurate but he
does need to resign he needs to resign
and if he won't resign he needs to be
fired i mean he has broken the trust of
the american people the republicans hold
the key
to funding
any increases in the us military budget
correct i mean if the republicans say
we're not doing this that's right that
military budget's not being increased
they're not getting their new weapon
systems or any of the things that the
generals always say they need
so it's incumbent upon the gop and
you're stepping up to say whoa whoa whoa
whoa this this military has got to be
reformed and then move on to the
diplomatic corps with blinkens
embarrassment
you know i i think what we're seeing
here these reports that we're seeing
laura i can't underscore enough how
dangerous this is how dangerous it is
for a general especially the chairman of
the joint chiefs to take into his own
hands the conduct of american foreign
policy to undermine elected
representatives including most
importantly the president of the united
states the elected president i mean this
is this is dangerous dangerous territory
that we're in and we're going to have to
get to the bottom of it there needs to
be a full congressional inquiry and i'm
again i'm sorry to say but it is it is
vital now that general miller he needs
to resign if he doesn't resign he needs
to be fired this is dangerous territory
that we're in and there's got to be
accountability senator great to see you
tonight thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else